say welcome welcome welcome to the what
is i course
series so we'll call it yeah series i am
skyra
i'm atlas all right thought i had to
introduce you and uh
we are what is i and the purpose of this
uh course distillation is to
break down and unpack our book make sure
that every chapter is fully understood
by you so you have a greater chance of
actually understanding what and who is i
yes and we felt like this format of a
course
where we
unpacked what we felt like was
the core of each chapter
would be
useful for you yeah in greater
understanding greater integration
greater realization and then how that
would then further ripple out into your
family friends the world right
yep yeah so we start with chapter one
yeah so each one of these will be
divided um into a couple minute video
per chapter yeah and
we're really excited we'll have some
nice fun embeds for you throughout as
well probably the chapter image as well
as uh maybe some overlaid graphics so
yes sir so nice let's begin
boom chapter
one what is i what is that so
what is the top thing that we want to
extract here for chapter one well we
were talking we felt like
the core
of chapter one needed to start with the
single word of investigate
yes
and i think that um
we're just not used to investigating
that's not a common thing for us to
investigate and try to break down or try
to deeply understand
the surface level things in our reality
because obviously the surface level
things aren't actually surface level um
and if you begin to investigate not only
yourself and the things around you you
gain a deeper understanding so that's
like the premise of this book
investigate and i feel also when you
investigate you come into the knowledge
you understand yourself instead of
someone telling you what they
investigated and now you don't have
really a
connection to that because you didn't
come to the understanding yourself so
yeah that's definitely the important of
actually investigating yeah
and so many
analogies are great here and i actually
used one in the tedx talk i gave in san
francisco about four years ago or so um
and the
idea was
most people spend their time at the
surface level of the ocean
right right up there at the top of the
ocean and it can be a little bit
challenging to deal with this
water pressure as you go to the abyss
right
but the abyss is where all of the juicy
wisdoms and nuggets of life can be found
absolutely so your classic question of
how are you or let's talk about the
weather or let's talk about current
events or sports or whatever
that's a lot of surface level
conversation but if you approach
somebody and you ask them
what is your north star what is your
mission what is your purpose
or if you ask them about hey what do you
think the nature of reality is
um
and so you can get to
through investigations through
the tedx talk was about the art of
powerful questions and how that's a
muscle to work out so if you
obsess about powerful questions
and
what is i
you start with that question in
self-inquiry
[Music]
and you become the detective and you
investigate
that will take you all the way
yeah and
most people have these surface level
conversations but they're very deep um
and like we said in
the book
see yourself as a mystery to be
uncovered that is actually that should
be your driving force for investigation
there's so much more to you that you
don't know and that you are yet to find
out or you have yet to find out and you
shall when you investigate whatever that
looks like for you
i think we can't we truly can't tell you
what investigation looks like for you
as we see a butterfly
fly away
but i can tell you for me
it's uh really questioning every single
thing i do even if it's like you know go
get the milk okay you know how am i
walking you know why do i choose this
vanilla almond milk instead of
unsweetened vanilla
this is everything and then you begin to
understand yourself at such a deeper
level that when you move and groove
awareness is all around you
yay
yep
and so
like
coming at it from this angle of
where should i look where is the most
important place to investigate
and then being like
okay well maybe the i before my name
is
the best place to look yes because you
say it all the time
you say i am john i am
i am chris
and we just never ask who is i what is
the i that is being described as chris
yeah look at the i
before your name
and just really think about that let's
break that down